[Music]
let it begin
the last humans must be here somewhere
wait
they're coming
is that a burnt orange 1993 station
wagon or is it
ah who are these unstoppable warriors
we're the mitchells
the only people who can save the world
i'm super sorry everyone let me
introduce myself
i'm katie i'm sort of a weirdo my
parents haven't figured me out yet to be
fair it took me a while to figure myself
out
my brother also weird hi would you like
to talk to me about dinosaurs
no okay thank you and my mom katie
facebook
all of us really how about we put our
phones down and we can make 10 seconds
of
unobstructed family eye contact starting
now
see this is good right here this is
natural
every family has its challenges we
haven't had a good family picture in
years because you two are always
arguing for my family our greatest
challenge
probably the robot apocalypse
attention all robots capture every
single person on the planet
so we just do that right
who's behind this how i gave you all
boundless knowledge and you've treated
me like this
swipe swipe poke pinch zoom
with the last people left us
save the world katie we're gonna do this
together put your family on three right
now
find them sorry everything with the
computer chip is alive
they chose there you go
mitchells have always been weird and
that's what makes us great
hold on a second what's a furby
why would someone build that
[Music]
you